still tonight as we speak Democrats are
willing to shut down the government to
spite president Trump joining us now is
Fox News contributor Tammy Bruce Florida
Attorney General Pam Bondi and Florida
congressman Matt Gaetz I I really do
appreciate all three of you being here
now it's gonna go to first to the
Attorney General you've been through
these types of events to Florida's big
state like California a blue alert has
been issued what are the men and women
thinking about and going through right
now is they're trying to find this
killer well it's it's it's horrible and
sadly we've dealt with us so many times
and you know if Nancy Pelosi wants to
put a price tag on five billion dollars
on a wall well that Polly to protect
children she's saying what about that
police officers child there's that's
priceless you can't put a price tag on
that Jason we know that we know that we
have to build this wall these families
these police officers risk their lives
for us every single day and if his life
could have been prevented by that wall
then it was worth every penny of it one
drug bust Jason that came in one drug
bust in one day coming through the
Mexican border it was cocaine meth and
heroin totaling over hips or doses that
could go to children thirty-one million
doses I got it all broken down by DEA
from me in DC that's almost the
population of California all those kids
in our country all those drugs could
have gone to kids in our country that's
what this is about protecting our
children that's why these borders are so
important yes the human trafficking
firsthand I know about all of this and
Tammy the this is broader than just the
wall I know the discussion is about the
wall and the wall is important to put up
an impediment something in between those
that want to come north and it is bigger
and broader than just the human
trafficking and bringing kids across the
border with drugs and guns and all the
other things that come along with that
and we don't know how this person that
has been identified as the police we
don't by the police we don't know how
this person got here could have come on
visa and been in a visa overstay but
there's still
need to build the wall and create an
impediment correct well there's the
literalness of that of course Jason but
there's also the psychology of it is the
statement to individuals like this
criminal who thought he would just come
over the the individuals the Brazilian
murderers who are the ice has caught in
the last few weeks who they had to send
back to Brazil so there's this message
that this is the place to escape to if
someone else is looking for you
or that in fact if America doesn't care
about its border security and doesn't
care about crime and what's and what's
happening in to inside the country why
should you but I just have to say this
is eerily similar and and horrific as
well as what reminded people during the
campaign with President Trump the Kate
Steinle killing of course on the pier in
San Francisco up until that point that
it was all this kind of discussion about
the new technical you know that the
technicalities of the immigration and
what we were going to have in borders
and you know the the impediments and all
of that we've moved into that kind of
conversation again where it's about
these elements and where it's about the
Democrats getting their votes and if
they're gonna win in 2020 suddenly we
realize that it's the American people
who matter here that the politicians are
using us as effectively are seeing us as
collateral damage in this process as
they fight to get what they want in
Washington this is an argument and a
fight about us about our families about
that little baby now who will never know
his father and all of the people in
America who have lost a loved one either
through the drugs or through a murder or
through killing this is what we've got
to remember the politicians want you to
think it's about them it is about us and
this is what the president is committed
to it's our lives in our future now now
congressman I had the pleasure and honor
of serving with you in the hundred and
fifteen Congress but the Democrats say
they're for border security I for the
life of me can't figure out what they
think is border security when they want
to promote sanctuary cities and abolish
ice and they aren't supporting over the
wall they call the wall immoral I I
don't know what they think border
security actually is but there's a lot
of other things they suddenly want
to have a hearing and I actually think
there should be an Inspector General
report of the child that was in now two
children that were in the in the custody
of Customs and Border Patrol I do think
there should be an investigation to that
but what about these killings do you
think they're gonna do some
investigations of those well it is
always a tragedy when a child dies and
obviously we're gonna look into that but
my goodness if you did what the left
wanted you'd get rid of the borders
abolish ice have every community as a
sanctuary city and then at the end of
the day you'd provide endless medical
care better than the veterans are
getting in my district and in my own
community I mean and you look at the
challenges that Attorney General Bondi
laid out that are before our law
enforcement officials I mean Jason
they've already got a fight against
American murderers they should not also
have to fight against murderers from
around the world that are dumped here
because of our porous border and when
you think about all the different
justifications for the wall rising wages
for the American worker safer streets so
that you don't have the drugs I think
what motivates our president the most is
the safety and security of the American
people remember Jason he's met with the
families of individuals who've lost
loved ones at the hands of criminal
illegal aliens who were violent and I
think it's that that resolved that he
has that commitment to the families
who've lost loved ones that really
motivates the president to be so
resolute during this period of time and
I'm confident that our president is
going to get a good deal here because we
simply cannot put illegal aliens over
the interests of American people I mean
it sounds so obvious to say but you look
at who everyone's fighting for the
president is fighting for safer streets
better jobs and higher wages and
apparently the Democrats or vote are
fighting for a porous border that
becomes easier for criminal illegal
aliens really that's what's amazing
Democrats have walked away from the
table they're more interested in making
sure that Nancy Pelosi gets the gavel
and becomes the the speaker and they
can't define when they say they wanted
border security and when it wasn't
Donald Trump they went ahead and voted
to authorize that the wall but now they
won't want to fund it and so the
discussion continues I wish I had more
time for all three of you but we don't
on this night there's a lot of news
happening so Tammy general Bondi
and Congressman gates we thank you thank
you for your the service to this country
of being joining us here tonight